hello and welcome to this video playing
five onyx with black practice it and you
like to practice this opening not
scoring badly it's not very exciting
here's the chronic chronic
kawana line from the candidates how do
you play that with black I did not study
this yet but sure come on up late that
just going to play normals and see what
happens okay so if I take and castle
short is that cannot be much for white
but maybe it's got a little pool down
let's see
his bishops are a little bit more active
but it cannot be the end of the world my
idea is to play c6 blunting this bishop
so c6 and yeah do you have anything
better than bishop of age yeah probably
not but it's not a big deal
just have to be a little bit of patience
here in this position then it should be
possible to equalize completely so if I
go rook d7 look the aged e5 there's
nothing going on I think what is he
doing there piling up on the deep deep
on maybe
interesting yeah it's a little bit
annoying that I cannot go Brooke the
aide and a 6 as the a pawn is hanging
mmm that is a bit annoying
and he's got pusher before increasing
this a little bit is pressure
okay mean if he goes better before I
still have worked the aid so it's not an
immediate threat here not not really
therefore I can still play
rookie aid my long-term ideas h5 Bishop
h6 took me a long time
trading trading the least active pieces
standard idea okay so the structure
changes very it really plays it well
yeah crazy interesting plays in an
interesting way so what's going on here
we see a truly age am i really worse
there if I I just don't think so
maybe I'm Lewis
okay now if I take it not be six should
be okay maybe I'm still slightly worse
nice can do all four things which spring
the king
I need the king
King T for the Roxy - okay yeah my suit
doesn't read no that much should be five
maybe and I'm activating this one
I've got 32 seconds but with the
increment not such a big deal once he
leaves the D file I get rock d1 to kick
the king away
Oh Kim I don't mind
Oh d3 check doesn't lead to much but
yeah I'm threatening d3 check and to the
pawn is attacked okay and another one is
it actually good to try to rule it's a
good question but I think it is actually
good because my rook is protecting every
single pawn that's nice I don't get the
a porno
I forgot that he has rook a 7 I really
really didn't pay attention to that
28 seconds people is fast so be to
immediately or between italy or p5
it's better a lot better
yeah it's actually still a bit of work
but I think I'm winning one of the
points they are queen g4 it's difficult
for them to to keep those that's a bit
of a pain he gets h5 it's not that's not
such an such an easy when considering
the time
I know it looks a bit passive but his
rook is also stuck to the defense of the
pawn
that's that's a window how do you win
that again check
chick
and that's it
you know who winning that is tough but
you know this is kind of the nature
sometimes of this opening you're kind of
defending and you're keeping it equal
and mmm it doesn't look so attractive
but if you want the technical game
something slower she can sometimes win
the endings I mean even here you
definitely can argue that I was worse I
mean this is a position where white is
better I definitely definitely didn't
play the opening well and here I'm yeah
it's just entirely defensive in nature
don't know if I was really in how much
worse I was I would just look at e8
that's very stupid I should do this song
yeah it's just completely equal I began
you cannot take him because of I thought
this but okay I just read the rules you
know yeah they were that's just equal
and I after d5c for white is better
Simone and before is better here huh he
didn't play before and this way I got
here I mean right a stupid choice but
he's somehow somehow bungled it up not
quite sure where he it's already kind of
okay but I think that the f4 f4 was the
Vietnam you know now I'm getting no
yeah he didn't he didn't play the ending
well I wonder however if I could have
played better here somewhere very likely
I could have I could be one that's a lot
stronger this and then d3 yeah that's
true
the point is actually very quick yeah
we'll be to next and I push it yeah
that's better
and this is actually debatable if I'm
winning six it seems to be a mistake
look a six well that makes sense
I need to a purpose cover threatened
threatened a fight huh
yeah it's also drawn yeah maybe I still
have slide show answers I know what the
b-pawn should win it's still a bit of
work but it is a winning position yeah
it was a defensive I had to defend the
whole time but somehow he did not play
the ending well thanks a lot for
watching